bueno creo que hoy tenemos que ver con
lo que nos encontramos precisamente a
pleno día la convención nacional
demócrata por un lado que ha terminado
oficialmente días atrás con joe va a ir
en el candidato confirmado a la
presidencia de los eeuu dando un
discurso que claramente perfila el rumbo
que tomarán los eeuu en caso de que éste
sea electo o no y que los demócratas
ganen el camino a la casa blanca yo creo
que acá es clave
identificar también cuáles son las
características y los factores que ambos
candidatos están utilizando
principalmente la cuestión del miedo no
por parte de bailén pero también esto es
algo que lo hace el presidente de donald
trump al plantear el escenario en el que
digamos el contrincante pudiera ser
electo ahora yo creo que el desafío que
se plantean los demócratas es
precisamente sacar a donald trump de la
presidencia definiendo claro cómo serían
esos eeuu que vendrían de la mano de
estos personajes políticos y yo creo que
es ahora en este preciso momento cuando
tanto el partido demócrata como el
partido
publicano empiezan a definirse yo creo
que con tintes nacionalistas muy
preocupantes y con algún sentido o tinte
de populismo no es interesante también
la elección que hizo bailén en su
fórmula presidencial ahora optando por
la senadora que ambos la sabes que en
caso de ganar claramente sería la
primera mujer vicepresidente de los eeuu
ahora hay que pensar cuáles son las
ideas y los programas de gobierno más
gasto público mayor presión tributaria
mayor estado y eso es algo que lo hemos
probado en américa sabemos que no
funcionan oye vale también para la
administración de donald trump en
toneladas según varios sondeos donald
trump se encontraría el día de hoy
alrededor de unos 8 puntos porcentuales
por debajo de su rival no de joe biden
al que atribuye usted esta diferencia a
algunos de analistas lo vinculan con la
gestión de la pandemia de coronavirus
por ejemplo
y yo creo que en buena parte esto tiene
que ver con la gestión de el coronavirus
y como se ha hecho el desenlace este año
en lo que va de este año pero también no
hay que dejar de lado las
características también de las que
hablábamos al principio que hoy nos
muestra el presidente de donald trump no
digo insisto estos tintes de
nacionalismo estos tintes de populismo
no creo que esto es algo también
importante para destacar que existen
populismos de izquierda pero también
existen populismos
de derecha yo por eso siempre insisto
mucho que los eeuu tienen que empezar a
repensar este sistema político y quizás
el sistema bipartidista no un país con
tanta historia del liberalismo clásico
con grandes raíces que históricamente
han representado la ciudad de la
libertad y del capitalismo por eso creo
que es hora de repensar incluso insisto
ese bipartidismo que se aferra tanto al
sistema político en los eeuu que incluso
desde los medios de comunicación fíjate
siempre se plantean opciones como aove y
no se le da espacio a las opciones de
hoy
y esto lo digo precisamente por el
partido libertario de los eeuu que
resulta también una estupenda opción con
propuestas concretas incluso respecto al
futuro y la libertad de los eeuu en este
caso en este caso con la candidata
libertaria jørgensen que tiene también
todo el derecho de participar en los
debates de las primarias es algo que
también se está se está teniendo en
cuenta ahora para sobre sobre esta
perspectiva aquí no tiene por qué ser
silenciada ni por los medios ni por ese
bipartidismo tan aferrado en los eeuu no
creo que son cosas que hay que plantear
antonella martín muchísimas gracias por
este completísimo análisis de la escena
política de eeuu realizado aquí en la
pantalla de france 24 por favor gracias
a usted es un placer